hello my name is ire Manuel the lead
maker for the gravity fed model and gas
and kit prototype in this project we are
collaborating with students from
background Secondary School
who are the members of the school
science and Innovation Club
our project is at a completion stage
we are now documenting it
for us critical making is about making
things that are aimed at solving
challenges of the community
our intended beneficiaries are the
vulnerable refugees to support them with
this gravity fed model
irrigation kits so that they can be able
to grow
basic food crops in times of reliable
rainfall and also during
dry seasons this will help them to
improve on their nutrition the overall
well-being so in a sense that our making
is a small contribution towards the
sustainable development goals of UN
yeah so we would love to produce as many
of these kits as possible thank you